früher habe ich die bibel gelesen heute
muss ich sagen ich glaube nicht dass es
einen gott gibt aber wer weiß vielleicht
gibt es ja doch einen und er ruft mich
irgendwann zu sich vielleicht kommt es
dazu denn ich habe in meinem leben viel
böses getan wenn ich eines tages
tatsächlich vor gott stehe und er sagt
hallo mein gott wenn wir nicht antworten
hallo ich bin schon dorset und glauben
dass es ihn gibt wo er nicht wie konnte
es so weit kommen dass dieser mann quasi
vor unser aller augen frauen auf
brutalste art und weise ausbeutete woher
kommen diese frauen und wieso schwiegen
viele trotz allem davon handelt dieser
film
[Musik]
das zürcher sihlquai war schon lange ein
trauriger ort gewesen doch dann kam die
personenfreizügigkeit für osteuropa
darunter ungarn und es wurde alles noch
viel schlimmer
schnell war der zürcher strassenstrich
ganz in der hand ungarische roma
dutzende von frauen schafften hier
plötzlich täglich an beaufsichtigt von
rücksichtslosen zuhältern mein cousin
hat mir erzählt dass man hier gut
verdienen kann
deshalb bin ich in die schweiz gekommen
und was für eine art geschäftes ging war
mir klar
also habe ich zwei mädchen organisiert
die mit mir hierher gekommen sind
die schweizer drogen prostituierten die
hier bis anhin auf den strich gegangen
waren kamen zusehends unter druck und
mussten das feld bald räumen sich
umbringen das ist viele unruhige und
sich aggressiv so wandeln omen für
nämlich ihnen soll sogar im hintergrund
projekt wieso abdecken die frau gegen
kontrollieren sollte ich auch für alle
vergeblich auf eine tauschen die polizei
erkannte schnell dass es um weit mehr
als nur um prostitution ging nämlich um
menschenhandel die ermittlungen gegen
hintermänner gestalteten sich schwierig
haben sie freund dem sie auch noch gelb
geben oder freiwillig nicht verstehen
anfangs wusste ich nicht wie es hier
läuft
ein anderer zuhälter haben wir dann
alles erklärt zum beispiel wie viel man
verlangen kann
er sagte mir keine angst hier macht uns
niemand kann liebe habe ich eingeladen
mit ihm zu gehen um mir die sache
anzuschauen
ich sagte nein lieber nicht ich will
nicht zurück ins gefängnis
er antwortete mach dir keine sorgen hier
machen wir was wir wollen dass man uns
anfangs so frei gewähren dies hat mich
doch sehr überrascht wurde innerhalb
kurzer zeit zur tonangebenden figur auf
dem zürcher strassenstrich
und die polizei begann langsam zu
verstehen mit was wir es zu tun hatte
nämlich mit einem ganzen netzwerk von
zuhältern die mit bisher unbekannter
brutalität vorgingen
dank monatelanger telefonüberwachung
gelang es das netz um den größten fisch
langsam zuzuziehen umschauen durch im
milieu bekommt als samurai so hat man
mich schon in ungarn genannt ich habe
den namen samurai bekommen weil es
einige male vorgekommen ist dass sich
streitigkeiten mit einem samurai-schwert
geregelt habe von hier stammt samurai
als bestes einem kleinen städtchen in
ostungarn nahe der rumänischen grenze
dank seiner kriminellen aktivitäten
hatte seine familie zu einigem wohlstand
gebracht etwa zu einem eigenen haus
seine familie hat der vor über sieben
jahren verlassen richtung schweiz
seine frau erzählt sie habe ihren
standort mit 17 das erste mal gesehen
und sich sofort in ihn verliebt in einen
netten und zuvorkommenden jungen mann er
sei ein familienmensch sagt sie
allerdings einer mit einem aufbrausenden
temperament mein mann hat zwei seiten
manchmal ist es ja gut aber er kann auch
schnell aggressiv werden ich wusste
jedoch immer dass in die familie alles
bedeutet
seine mutter erzählt ihr mann sei früh
verstorben und chamdo der älteste ihrer
fünf söhne sei baut darauf auf die
schiefe bahn geraten
er hatte keine träume ist ja schon mit
17 ins gefängnis gekommen
das war mitte der 80er jahre noch im
tiefsten kommunismus ein ungarischer
dokumentarfilmer sie in der zeit gibt
einen einblick in diese gefängnis welt
in die süd bereits mit 17 zum ersten mal
gekommen ist eine prügelei hatte ihm
vier jahre freiheitsentzug eingebracht
der anfang eines lebens als
berufsverbrecher
eigentlich wollte er immer nur geld
verdienen um mir das leben leichter zu
machen
aber die wipper hat ihn leider schon
sehr früh gewissen von der lippe
gebissen worden zu sein das heißt der
brutale gefängnisalltag führte zu einer
art infektion mit dem bösen das
vertrauen in ihn blieb
auch sutter lebte szenen wie diese er
der bis dahin ein politischer mensch
gewesen war lernte bei den schlägereien
unter gefangenen eine lektion für sein
weiteres leben nicht die anständigen
kommen ans ziel sondern die
rücksichtslosen über die grausamkeiten
da wurde mir klar es kann keinen gott
geben sonst nicht er das nicht zu die
schwachen waren freiwild lernte süd der
respekt wollte musste sich einen namen
machen
entschuldigen sie wenn ich das so sage
aber einen mann der im gefängnis
geschickt worden ist
denn nimmt keiner mehr ernst der muss
von keinem mehr etwas wollen den
lachmann aus
immerhin vier jahren gefängnis hatte ich
viele schlägereien und ich habe meistens
gewonnen habe ich mir langsam einen
namen gemacht
mir wurde dann immer mehr angedichtet
ich hätte dieses getan oder jenes
gemacht weil ansehen stieg stieg die
leute hatten angst vor mir da musste ich
immer weniger kämpfen wenn mein ruf
eilte mir voraus
auch in schweizer medien hat sich süd
schnell einen namen gemacht bis in die
polizei am 15 juni 2008 verhaftete die
anklageschrift der staatsanwaltschaft
liest sich wie das drehbuch zu einem
horrorfilm von einer durch schläge und
tritte herbeigeführten abtreibung
statistischen exzessen und
gewerbsmässiger menschenhandel ist hier
die rede
ich kann nicht erklären wie es so weit
kommen konnte mit meinem sohn
ich denke er ist in schlechte
gesellschaft geraten und fing an drogen
zu nehmen
er ist schon von zu hause weggegangen
und wir hatten keinen einfluss mehr auf
ihn wird unter anderem wegen
menschenhandel vergewaltigung und
körperverletzung verurteilt seinen
opfern möchte ich sagen ich bedauere was
ich euch angetan haben doch ihr wisst
dass ich auch für dinge verurteilt wurde
die ich nicht gemacht haben aber es ist
müßig noch darüber zu diskutieren
ich habe meine strafe bekommen und
sitzen sie jetzt ab das urteil 14 jahre
gefängnis plus anschliessende verwahrung
informationsvorteil weiter erfahren und
das ist vierter vor folter in der
schweiz stellen kreieren
auf patrouille mit der stadtpolizei
zürich im kreis 46 jahre nach süd
verhaftung ist der plan aufgegangen
hatte das harte urteil tatsächlich eine
abschreckende wirkung sind ungarische
prostituierte und ihre hintermänner aus
dem stadtbild verschwunden
diese zwei jungen frauen sind der
polizei sofort aufgefallen sie schaffen
offenbar an und warten hier auf
kundschaft
es stellt sich heraus beide ungarinnen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
wenn sie mich fragen hat sich an der
situation nicht viel geändert
prostitution ist ja nach wie vor erlaubt
also machen die zuhälter die [ __ ]
weiter wie zuvor
eine der jungen ungarinnen führt die
polizei in ein schäbiges zimmer in einem
hinterhof der langstrasse
sie ist gestern mit dem nachtzug aus
budapest angekommen erzählt sie die
arbeiter auf eigene rechnung einen
zuhälter habe sie nicht
mit gott du was noch
es gibt keinen hinweis auf einen
zuhälter die polizei kann die frau im
moment einzig dazu anhalten eine
bewilligung für ihre tätigkeit
einzuholen polizei gehen
ok zeughausstraße 31 versuchen
bewilligung holen kann
die polizei hat sechs jahre nach süd
verhaftung immer noch die gleichen
probleme mich vorher und die aussage
einer frau ist sie machtlos
die frauen werden nach wie vor ruß
genutzt und polizei mussten extrem viel
aufwand betrieben um apples online
meetings verfahren zu eröffnen
menschenhandel und zwangsprostitution
ist das problem dein größtes problem ist
sicher nicht gelöst es ist nach wie vor
so dass die prostitution in der stadt
zürich stattfindet ist noch wo das die
frau hilflos ausgesetzt sind erwartet
aber auch nach wie vor auf der a16 zum
den olymp lag die zürcher straßen
prostitution wurde inzwischen neu
geregelt am sihlquai ist das anschaffen
seit august 2013 verboten
als alternative hat die stadt in aus
städten gleichzeitig einen überwachten
strichplatz eröffnet mit sogenannten
verrichtungsboxen so wollten die
verantwortlichen unter anderem auch die
macht der zuhälter brechen denn die
haben hier keinen zutritt mehr
das ist lachhaft
wichtig ist nur eins dass die [ __ ] dem
zuhälter am ende das geld bringt dafür
muss er sie doch nicht bei der arbeit
beaufsichtigen
damit dieses geschäft funktioniert muss
dazu hält er nicht vor ort sein
er ist sowieso immer auf distanz er geht
ja auch nicht mit aufs zimmer und schaut
zu
wer verstehen will wieso männer wie
frauen finden die sich ausbeuten lassen
und mehrheitlich schweigend der muss
nach osten reisen zum beispiel nach
mischpults mit 170.000 einwohnern die
viertgrößte stadt ungarns
während des kommunismus florierte hier
die schwerindustrie
doch dann kam die wende und mit ihr der
ökonomische quasi kollaps wer konnte der
ging die meisten roma blieben
sie leben in speziellen quartieren in
eigentlichen ghettos für menschenhändler
reservoire potenzieller opfer
hier gibt es keine kanalisation in
keinem haus fließendes wasser und auch
keine perspektive juli 22 und bereits
vater von zwei kindern arbeit hat er
keine
wie auch sonst niemand in der
großfamilie man lebe von der hand in den
mund sagt er
wir hatten wir ein zusätzliches kleines
gebäude
das mussten wir abreißen es drohte
einzustürzen
hier haben wir beim thema schlamm
warum haben wir diese steine hingelegt
damit niemand ausrutscht
das ist das holz das wir heizen können
im winter außerdem sammeln wie eisen und
verdienen ein wenig zeit die wir es zu
einer sammelstelle bringen
das hier ist unsere toilette
nun soll diese roma siedlung
verschwinden denn der lokale fußballklub
braucht ein neues stadion inklusive
parkplätze für die fanbusse diese
parkplätze könnten freilich auch auf der
industriebrache hinter dem stadion
entstehen
und nicht dort wo die roma im moment
leben alles nur ein vorwand der
stadtregierung sagen die roma man wolle
sie einfach weghaben aus mit gold
der bürgermeister lässt ausrichten er
habe keine zeit für ein interview
schließlich empfängt uns der
vize-bürgermeister stimmt das dass die
roma aus der stadt raus sollen
er stimmt wenn ich ein mit einem wort
ihnen die antwort geben müsste aber ich
bin der meinung dass ein journalist
werden nicht so schneiden dass es in dem
film bleibt ich bitte sie nicht so
lassen es stimmt nicht mit einer
erweiterten antwort und zwar sie müssen
es so verstehen in der stadt diskurs
gibt das 345 ich möchte jetzt nicht ganz
genau sagen
solche touren solche gebiete die
verstehen sie mich wenn ich sage aslam
gezeigt wieso der ernannt wird
und dieses problematisches gebiet
möchten die selbstverständlich erneuern
und damit diese erneuerung möglich ist
müssen die roma weg den winter dürfen
barbara und ihre familie noch bleiben
danach stehen sie auf der straße und
müssen dringend an geld kommen egal wie
ideale opfer die alles tun würden um die
bevorstehende tragödie abzuwenden
ich glaube es kommt schlecht
wir wissen nicht wo wir hin und wenn wir
keinen festen wohnsitz mehr annehmen sie
uns die kinder weg es ist hoffnungslos
dass hier eine art ethnische säuberung
im gange ist bestreitet die stadt
entschieden man wolle jedoch keine
volksgruppe loswerden heißt es sondern
lediglich problematische individuen
sie wollen nicht arbeiten
sie wollen die gas elektrizität
wassergebühren nicht zahlen und sie
machen
kriminalität nur mit dieser minderheit
haben wir das problem verstehen sie mich
richtig lieber schweizerischer zuschauer
nur mit der minderheit der sich nicht
wohlfühlen in der stadt bis sport und
nicht arbeiten wollen wie sich nur nicht
so benehmen wollen die es normal ist
kann ich ihnen nichts anderes sagen wir
machen nichts verwalten
wir sammeln eisen damit wir uns brot
erhoffen können vom staat bekommen wir
nicht einmal 200 franken pro monat
davon muss die ganze familie leben aber
das reicht nicht wir wissen davon sturm
wasser und abfall gebühren bezahlen
besten brauchen wir auch und windeln wie
die kinder
wir wollen arbeiten aber und stellt
niemand ein weil die roma sind also
versuchen wir sonst irgendwie an geld zu
kommen
dadurch wollen wir zum beispiel eine
wiege machen und sie verkaufen
es stimmt
nicht handeln aber wir sind anständige
leute keine kriminellen in ihrer
verzweiflung flüchteten kürzlich 65 roma
smiths in die schweiz und beantragten in
waller brasil dass ungarn aus einem
eu-land waren wurde er gesucht noch
nicht einmal geprüft
sie mussten umgehend wieder abreisen wir
haben nichts mehr
sogar unsere betten haben wir verkauft
um die reise in die schweiz zu bezahlen
jetzt sind wir zurück stehen vor dem
nichts
alles was jetzt noch fehlt ist ein
menschenhändler der der familie einen
ausweg verspricht einen diese
menschenhändler hat die schweiz aus dem
verkehr gezogen
santos audi of samurai ist in der jva wo
es verwahrt
das heißt er wird aller voraussicht nach
im gefängnis sterben
anfangs war schwierig aber langsam
beginne ich die realität zu akzeptieren
was soll ich sonst machen
vielleicht gibt es leute die in einer
solchen situation an selbstmord denken
würden ich nicht
ich habe zwei kinder die mich manchmal
besuchen kommt ihrem gefängnis kann ich
arbeiten und ein wenig geld verdienen
damit unterstütze ich sie wenn ich mich
um rechte würde ich mir selber zwar
helfen aber man kindern würdig schaden
das will ich nicht
rund 100 franken fliessen so pro monat
nach ostungarn zu seinem sohn der
genauso heißt wie sein vater
santoro junior möchte profifußballer
werden und seiner familie künftig ganz
legal ein besseres leben ermöglichen bin
ich irgendwann viel geld verdiene werde
ich vieles kauften für mich und für
meine schwester und für meine mutter die
tochter von 623 die verbrechen ihres
vaters appell der familie zu einem
eigenen haus verholfen
zu einer perspektive für ihr junges
leben in das nicht obwohl sie als
hochbegabt gilt ist sie bereits jetzt
sicher dass sie nie eine stelle finden
werde
weil sie eine rom sei ja ich bin traurig
ich wünsche mir eine bessere zukunft
aber die wahrheit ist es ist leider
nicht möglich
[Musik]
nein in dieser geschichte gibt es kein
happy end für niemanden und auch keine
hoffnung dass es besser wird
[Musik]